- Welcome back, everybody we've
got Sofia Vergara with us!
(crowd cheers)
Her new Netflix series
is called "Griselda"
It's about a Colombian
woman's unlikely rise
to become one of the most
notorious crime bosses in Miami.
And if you are a crime
boss, you've always got
to be looking behind you.
So, it's time for another round of
"What's Creepin' Up On Me?"
(intense rock music)
(crowd cheers)
♪ What's creepin' up on me ♪
- All right, so here's how it works.
(audience cheers)
Sofia will start with
her back to the screen.
I will give her clues
about what's creeping up behind her,
Which I normally am not super great at.
So, whatever.
- Oh, no!
- I can't say the name
of the thing, I just gotta describe it.
So, then we're gonna switch sides
and Sofia will give me clues.
Hopefully she's better.
We can pass if anything is too hard
to guess, which I always
forget by the way,
and should totally use that.
If we can correctly guess 10
things total in two rounds,
Sofia has a prize for the audience.
So, let's get into position.
- Well wait, what things?
Things in general?
Or movies or cars?
- Anything in the world.
I have no idea what's
about to happen.
- Okay.
- I am so bad at this game.
- Oh, great.
- I think that's why they
like me to play it.(laughs)
- It's okay.
- Well it's the "Kelly
Clarkson Show", so who knows?
Here we go.
All right, so, I'm ready.
Go.
Okay.
Oh! You're on the ocean.
On a craft of some sort.
And you're going, it's not a-
- In a jet ski.
- Yes.
(bell rings)
(crowd cheers)
Yes.
Go! Quickly!
Oh!
What? Oh!
When people die, they're in the morgue
and they put their
names on like, something
on their feet.
And put like "Jane Doe".
- On their feet?
- You know, like a like a...
Okay, when you're a kid,
you played a game and you would go
and chase them and you would...
- You will scare them?
- Next! Next!
- Touch them!
Okay.
Oh!
This is, oh, the friendliest little thing
in the ocean.
And they go in like, they swim like this
and they'd dive up and down.
- The seal.
- No, no.
(crowd laughs)
- The turtle.
Flipper!
Skipper?
What the hell is the name?
- Oh, the dolphins!
(bell rings)
- Yes! Yes.
(crowd cheers)
Okay!
So, the character you play went to?
- Jail.
- Which is also called?
- Punishment.
(crowd laughs)
- Which is also called?
What's another word for jail?
(bell rings)
Prison!
- Oh, okay.
- Cool!
(crowd cheers)
- Oh!
This is like, this is like, people do it
on the boardwalk and at a-
- Bad dancing.
(crowd laughs)
- No, like.
- What?
What is that?
(crowd laughs)
What?
- I don't dance like that!
You know!
- Skateboarding?
- No, the other-
- Rollerblading!
- Roller skates!
You got it.
- Okay.
- Oh!
This happens in Florida a lot.
And it's like, the wind is crazy.
The ocean is crazy.
- Hurricane!
(bell rings)
- Okay.
(crowd cheers)
- Oh!
This is like, prehistoric.
And in the-
- Dinosaur.
- Well, it kind of, it's prehistoric
in a sense of like, but it's still around
and it's not a crocodile.
- Hieroglyphic!.
It's not a crocodile.
It's a.
It's an.
- It's a cro-
- The other one!
Not a crocodile.
- It's a dinosaur.
- No.
It's not a crocodile.
It's the other one.
The shorter one.
- Hippopotamus!
- (censored).
You can get boots that are made of this.
- Oh, crocodile!
What?
Of the snakes!
(bell dings)
(crowd laughs)
(horn honks)
You are so horrible! (laughs)
I love that you said I
dance like that. (laughs)
Switch! Switch!
- No!
- You can see how easy it is!
I do not dance
like that.
- Concentrate!
Concentrate!
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Okay.
- I'm in.
I'm in.
- Okay, go!
- Okay.
- And you go around!
- Oh, hula hoop!
- Yes.
(bell dings)
- Yeah, yeah.
(crowd cheers)
- Griselda made a lot of-
- Money! Money!
That cash, dough.
(ball rings)
- Yes.
- And in Miami there's a lot of, pink.
- Flamingos!
(bell rings)
- You're really good.
- And then in the pool, when you go, "Ah!"
- You dive or you-
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- But with your-
- Cannonball!
- No.
- Belly flop!
- Yes.
- Okay.
(crowd cheers)
- Ay! Ay!
(heel clacks)
(crowd laughs)
- Mosquito?
- No!
They're in the land.
And you go and you...
its an insect!
- You didn't even say
insect til' just now!
Do you know how many things
could bite you or sting you?
A bee?
No, in the floor!
- I think we're done.
- It's from the floor?
- I mean, really?
- Really?
(audience laughs and cheers)
You think I'm weird and
you didn't get alligator?
(crowd cheers)
You didn't get alligator! (laughs)
I wanna do a game night with you!
- Oh, we got it!
Oh!
- We got it?
- [Producer] That was a bonus, you got it.
- Oh, hat was a bonus?
We got ten, we did it!
- Oh, my God!
- We did it!
(crowd cheers)
Toty's 360 degree sun
care products are driven
by science and innovation
to help preserve your skin health
and make you feel mas bonita.
They're vegan, cruelty free
and full of, is it alegria?
- Alegria.
- Alegria!
Just like their founder Sofia.
Is that joy?
Is that what, yeah.
- Yes. Happiness.
Yes.
- I like it. Okay.
And you're all going home
with a $200 Toty gift card.
(crowd cheers)
Give it up for Sofia Vergara!
You killed that game, it was so fast!
- We killed it!
- We did good!
Be sure to watch her
new series "Griselda",
it premiers tomorrow on Netflix!